make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay we are continuing on into our video
series on Secret Wars and we are
covering part three the earth
superheroes vs. Galactus but before we
start to this this video is sponsored by
Skillshare so Skillshare is an online
learning community that offers
membership with meaning with so much to
explore real projects to create and the
support of fellow creatives Skillshare
empowers you to accomplish your goals
one of my favorite classes is real
productivity how to build habits that
last which is taught by Thomas Frank in
this class you learn things like how to
determine your goals how to set yourself
up for success how to use external
systems and probably one of the most
important aspects what to do when you
fail and how to keep yourself motivated
so if you're looking to expand on your
skills or gain new ones and you also
want to do this in an incredibly
affordable way especially when compared
to pricy in-person classes and workshops
then Skillshare is giving away two free
months of premium membership to help you
explore your creativity if you click the
link in the description box and after
that it's only around ten dollars a
month you know now that I think about it
I feel like I should go on Skillshare
and teach people how to become a come-up
with youtubers that'd be pretty awesome
but in the last video we were talking
about how or at least we ended the video
basically with Galactus forming his ship
for the purpose of like consuming
battleworld right cuz let's collect is
this thing he usually brings a ship with
in the part city needs or on the ship
it's better than just toting them around
right like a like just walking around
like a giant backpack you know just like
like all like just throwing it on his
back like Peter McKinnon style and then
just like consuming world's Galactus
with a cup of coffee and you like like
giving you tutorials on how to consume
worlds but nonetheless in the last video
we talked about how Galactus was
basically in the process of getting
ready to consume all of battle world and
what this does is it says up a pretty
tricky situation for the heroes you've
already got a lot of infighting that's
one of the things we've kind of
discussed here is a lot of the
infighting going on insofar as everybody
kind of parceling themselves out and
forming their own different factions
right so the x-men have their own
faction the Avengers have their own
faction the villains have their own
faction that kind of goes down from
there and then in turn now you have a
bigger threat in the form of Galactus
now the benefit of this is that it
unites everybody right it's kind of the
unifying factor it's the immediate
threat and the truth is that given the
nature of Galactus it'll take pretty
much everybody to be involved in this in
order to pull it off now the other part
here and this is this is kind of a funny
thing the other part here is that
Nasus is sort of thinking about kitty
pryde the fact that he's so far from her
the fact that he misses her he's just
kind of daydreaming and thinking about
it when Xavier appears out of nowhere
he's like Colossus come at once you know
what it's like Colossus stopped hugging
on it you know like it's it's kind of a
funny little thing I always thought that
was entertaining but in any event one of
the things that I hope you guys were
noticing about Xavier in this story is
that his patience is exceedingly thin
right he's acting a lot more like a jerk
then you would normally expect it's
somebody to kind of take note of
something to kind of keep in the back of
your mind now the other part of this is
the molecule man I remember the molecule
man is essentially the most powerful
being in the universe all via Owen Reese
doesn't really use his powers to his
full extent and we'll find out why as we
progress further through secret Wars but
of course he's found a kind of romance
in volcana
right in in Marshall Rosenberg and so
they end up running up on a handful of
these guys and some of them start giving
him right they start giving them a hard
time and the result of this is that the
molecule man is like okay so like like
one of them calls him and calls him like
a nerd or something like that
any INLA he starts to freak out so he
basically turns the guy's suit into like
metal he alters the molecules or the
atoms of its suit turns it into metal
and then just leaves in there and then
Martius stomps his face into the ground
now this is a very important lesson to
understand kids violence is not always
the answer that's true but it is a
answer and it's usually a very effective
one so just something to keep in mind if
you're gonna pick a fight make sure it's
a fight you can win but at the end of
the day of course this is also one of
the crazy displays of Owen Reese's
powers is he basically uses the atoms of
the air around him to kind of coalesce
them into various molecules and then
form a kind of chariot for him and
volcana to basically fly off on now I
want you to think about that for a
second the molecule man altered the
atomic and subatomic structure of matter
so that he could create a chariot out of
thin air using the the atoms around him
in the air and then in turn used his
power to fly it's a ridiculous display
of power and these are the kind of
things that you're seeing I'm hoping
that if you're familiar with Owen Reese
and even if you're not right I mean he
never really used a whole lot of his
power and a really grand scheme it's not
really like this you know previously
it's the small little things like this
that highlight the idea that Owen Ruiz
is beginning to learn how to use his
power more effectively now the next
thing that you get is you get
enchantress showing up to Doctor Doom
now normally I would just kind of skim
past this but this is exceedingly
important and the reason why is because
enchantress is one of these characters
where she's been around for a very very
very long time and she's fought some
very
heavy-hitters right when a scart was
invaded by man god she was there right
like she was there watching it all go
down and so she knows how dangerous like
big level threats can be what you end up
getting here is you end up getting
enchanted who's who's seen some pretty
heavy hitters and understands the
severity of the situation remember in
the first issue Galactus tried to go
after the Beyonder and was batted away
like an insect and then sent crashing
down to battle world where he was left
unconscious for a short amount of time
right so like the Beyonder knocked
Galactus out cold without even really
physically touching him right just like
kind of with a spray of his powers
really how that happened and so when
Chantry is understanding the grand
scheme of things really kind of goes to
Doctor Doom and it's just like we should
leave this place right like there's a
kind of barrier that prevents us from
leaving but given your your knowledge of
sorcery given my knowledge of magic and
sorcery and so on and so forth we can
find a way to leave and initially dr.
Doom's response is no like that's not
going to happen you know I'm going to
take the prize of the Beyonder and I'm
gonna get everything that I that I've
ever desired and then enchantress
actually offers to fix the face of
Doctor Doom now one death that's kind of
one of the big talking points of his
character right the fact that his face
was scarred and you know at one point in
the past and if you read books of doom
you get one origin if you read Stan Lee
and Jack Kirby's Fantastic Four annual
number two which I actually have the
physical copy of which is amazing why
did you get another origin but
nonetheless the face of Doctor Doom was
scarred largely as it's believed that it
was scarred uh not in the explosion he's
sustained in college but when he
basically started forming his his his
armor and then he put the hot mask on
his face
that's what scarred his face right but
regardless it's always kind of been one
of these things where he's always tried
to find a way to cure his scars so we
can take his mask off when enchantress
offers that for a moment dr. doom takes
it but then immediately says no that's
not going to happen because what I have
to gain by taking the power of the
Beyonder dwarfs whatever you can give me
with your magics and your your seductive
nature and so on and so forth and so the
result is a basically similar packet now
of course you know with her she just
coming okay you know let's leave but
she's absolutely terrified of what could
happen here because the truth is they
could all really die right like the the
possibility of their death is a real in
a tangible thing now the other thing
about this this is one of the coolest
displays of Galactus power is that with
what he's trying to do in terms of
reconstitute his machinery and then
consume all the energies of battle world
and basically leave it a dead husk and
killing everybody on it in the process
is you have Charles Xavier and you have
magneto who really kind of try to create
this sort of beacon and trying to get
the attention of Galactus or Reed
Richards and all them are sort of
looking at what's
going on Galactus just kind of looks
towards the direction of Xavier and and
Magneto and blows up that portion of the
Citadel right just like just detonates
it right now it's it's it's an easy
thing to look over but understand this
like Galactus just looks over their
direction and presumably destroys a huge
portion of their vessel right without
even going to it without even like
walking over there and like channeling
his power through his hands or anything
like that
that's the kind of power that we're
talking about here it's interesting it's
a small little thing I always love
seeing stuff like that but I thought it
might be interesting to point attention
to the other part of this is that what
he is up doing is summary of summoning a
device of his own creation to deal with
the Avengers and to deal with with all
the forces who were there and that's one
of the things to remember about Galactus
right he doesn't really care about the
goings-on of mortals they don't matter
to him and in truth it kind of makes
sense why Galactus was born into this
universe he's gonna die with this
universe and be born into the next one
right he'll live for all over all
eternity right so long as the multiverse
continues to exist and any one universe
or this universities in can die and be
reborn again Galactus will always live
on now we know from furious stories in
the past that we've seen and with a
history of the malla universe by Mark
Waid that Galactus and and Franklin
Richards will actually merge into a
singular being and then be born into the
next universe but Galactus doesn't care
right I mean for the life and death of
any one of the superheroes passes like
that in the eyes of Galactus right in
the time that he's been around in the
billions of years he's existed and the
billions of more years that he will
exist there life will have been a moment
and talk so he doesn't care about any of
them it's really kind of beneath him to
like engage in a physical fight instead
he sends out somewhat of a proxy and by
and large this proxy isn't really
designed to overpower and destroy the
heroes it's designed to keep them
distracted keep them away right so it's
like being tracked by a by a whole bunch
of hungry wolves and then just like
killing some deer and leaving it there
for the Wolves to feed on so they're not
coming after you and for the most part
they're initially successful here
insofar as the heroes managed to take
down this you know this massive robot
and that's kind of the end of that but
then from there you also had the
villains who end up showing up with
regards to the heroes themselves right
the heroes facing off against the
villains a fight kind of breaks out yet
again and for the most part the fight
plays out the way you would expect it to
but here's the important thing that goes
on here while Galactus is doing all this
while Galactus is focusing on building
his machinery and while the heroes and
the villains are all facing off against
each other the x-men and the Avengers
are fighting against all the villains
what you have is Doctor Doom and this is
the important thing this is this is a
reason why dr. doom is so dangerous
because Doctor Doom
is an opportunist he's exceedingly smart
and he can usually create his own
opportunities but if one presents itself
to him he will take it and what he's
been looking for is a way to basically
usurp the power of Galactus that's what
he's been looking for all this time a
way to take the power of Galactus and
then in turn try to find a way to steal
the power of the Beyonder and so while
everybody is engaging in all these
fights and Galactus is distracted doing
his thing and the heroes and villains
are distracted doing their thing what
you get is Doctor Doom who basically
boards the ship of Galactus and when he
gets in there he starts kind of poking
around taking a look seeing what's going
on when he gets in there what you would
know having here is you end up having a
return of Ulysses Klaw now here's the
funny thing about this right ulysses
klaw coming back it doesn't matter but
if you're just kinda like well mean like
who cares about that
you're right nobody cares nobody cares
that Ulysses claws back the reason why
he's back in the way in which he
quote-unquote died is hilarious so like
wouldn't up happening is in Dazzler
volume 1 issue number 9 ulysses klaw
however reading this it was terrible
ulysses klaw ends up running up on on
Dazzler right and Dassler has the
ability to absorb sound and turn it into
light energy so literally ulysses klaw
is made of sound so he goes running up
on her and she's like nah I got time for
this and she just like absorbs him and
that's basically it like he does he gets
he was totally deuced on by Dazzler she
just like absorbs him into herself and
she's like all done folks back to what
you were doing and that's basically it
now the funny thing is that takes place
in issue number 9 and issues 10 and 11
she's taken by Galactus to become his
Herald in order to basically free and
and and and get back Terrax the tamer
and that's kind of a funny thing because
when the questions asked by Doctor Doom
like like why are you here like how did
you manage to get here like why are you
on Galactus ship what you find out is
that when dowser was taken by Galactus
she initially tried to fight and she
blasted Galactus with a whole bunch of
light energy which was basically heard
is kind of like dispelling a ulysses
klaw and when that happened ulysses car
really kind of seemed a vibrator remain
within the physical ship itself and then
ultimately was coalesced down into this
energy form that dr. doom ultimately
released but it's kind of funny because
as soon as ulysses klaw is done telling
this story doctor dooms like whatever
man i don't care like you bore me and
which is pretty much the response of
everybody who's reading this story
everybody was just kind of like see
Lucy's claw man like he's easily ever
done like one good thing and that was
invade Wakanda and that was it
nonetheless the idea of Doctor Doom is
to usurp the power of Galan
to steal the power of Galactus so what
he does is he basically forms a plan
with ulysses klaw and says you're gonna
go down to the surface and you're gonna
give this plan to them you're gonna tell
you what's going on at least insofar as
what I want them to know and that's
basically going to be it but what it
does is it brings all the villains
basically to this giant volcano that
kind of exists out there and then of
course Charles Xavier using his powers
to kind of scan the minds of everybody
ultimately coming across the Enchantress
who's just like get out of my head your
powers suck and then just like shuts
them out
ultimately leads to Xavier bringing the
x-men back and then in turn sending him
on this mission but here's an important
thing that goes on here storm as it
stands right now is the leader of the
x-men right this came as part of the end
of the Dark Phoenix saga and the fallout
to the end of the Dark Phoenix saga when
Cyclops was basically leaving the x-men
team and there was a kind of duel that
took place between him and storm to
determine who the leader of the team
should be and storm ultimately ended up
winning and so because storm overpowered
Cyclops
she was now the field commander Cyclops
left to do his own thing which really
went into like Madeline prior and all
that kind of good stuff in the birth of
cable so on so forth but storm was not
one of the woods she really didn't fall
rank-and-file with Cyclops
insofar as Cyclops was a believer right
he was a person that you couldn't sweat
you couldn't convince him that Xavier
was wrong
he believed 100% in the dream and the
truth is that while storm believes in
the idea of the dream she doesn't see
everything exactly the way that Xavier
does and so where Xavier is is really
being a really acting a lot like a dick
in a lot of ways storm calls them out
and it's just like I'm the one who
commands the x-men team you're the
teacher right you're the instructor
you're there you're the tutor and that's
cool and everything but don't be
confused about your place in the bigger
picture when it comes to us going out on
missions the fact that you're here
doesn't change anything in relation to
what it is that I do what I view is I
command the team when we're out in the
field right now we're out in the field
you just happen to be out here with us
but understand I'm the one making the
orders I'm the one making the call I'm
the one that tells people what to do let
me do my damn job that's basically her
response here and it's kind of cool
because Xavier Lydia doesn't seem to
back down he's kind of like no the
stakes are usually high you can't
possibly seem to fathom and understand
it and all that kind of stuff and storms
like I don't care it's my job to command
the team if you have insight give me
insight but do not take my job away from
me I will do my job myself you know and
it's a cool moment it's one of these
things that that the gym shooter was
really good at kind of continuing on the
writing of Chris Claremont if only for a
small degree but he couldn't do this for
the long term ultimately he would lose
himself in his own style of
and everything Chris Claremont did what
kind of go away but in this moment right
here it really is an almost perfect
reflection of what Chris Claremont would
have done because he wanted he would
have written it the exact same way you
also get a few other things going on
here for example a colossus is really
starting to dream more of this this girl
you know saasy i think it's how you
pronounce her name or Saji who's one of
the local villagers who's been running
around healing people what you have
right now is Johnny Storm who's
basically in love with this chick and
they're like hanging out and dating am i
kissing and hugging and all that kind of
cool stuff and so Colossus is developing
feelings too which is kind of messed up
because like Colossus man here's look
here's the thing man Colossus you got to
get up on that game man because if you
if you if you let it keep going the way
it is Johnny storms gonna get the girl
and you're gonna be left standing there
feeling sad and bad for yourself men do
what you got to do right all's fair in
love and war right so let's that's
basically yeah you know and so and but
the thing about Colossus is he's kind of
torn right on one side it's Kitty Pryde
who is his love interest back on earth
on the other side is this chick he just
met who he feels like he's in love with
but doesn't really know that well right
you know so it was really more feelings
of infatuation than anything else ah but
it's kind of leading Colossus a little
bit torn and even to some degree a
little bit heartbroken you know with
regards to the fact that Johnny storms
with this chick you know doing doing the
other there doing the damn thing and
like Colossus is just like laying in a
bed you know wishing he was with Kitty
Pryde but also kind of likes this chick
to make a choice man like quit quit
resting on your laurels make a choice
and do something but what the x-men
basically tracking the various villains
down to this massive volcano and then
all of them really sort of engaging in a
fight with each other things get kind of
interesting here right because as a
volcano begins to erupt right as it
begins to sort of go off the x-men bail
and instead the question kind of becomes
like how can anybody stop Galactus right
so this one doesn't really end but on
the same kind of cliffhanger as the ones
we've seen before right but the question
is can anybody stop Galactus and how
does anybody do it the answer is
actually gonna come in a more
interesting way than you probably think
though would that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here two comments explained
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]